the most comfortable men's boxers and
t-shirts you'll ever find are at leisure
of NYC their Ultra Soft bamboo boxers
feel as light as air and their silky
smooth supima cotton crewneck t-shirts
are amazing I love them you'll get 15
off with code Pacman at davidpackman.com
NYC let's start today with the U.S
Mexico border no matter how many times
the right Wingers say it the U.S Mexico
border is not open under Joe Biden now
you might be saying David of course it's
not open how could anyone believe that
it is open there are millions of people
based on polling that believe the border
is open under Joe Biden as a result of
some change or series of changes that
were put in place when Donald Trump left
and when Joe Biden became the president
of the United States this is not true
and we're going to look at it right now
and the reason we're going to look at it
is it's good to Once get everything on
the record so that in the future when
this talking point comes up when the
Maga people call me on the Friday show
and they say but the border is open
that's one of the problems I have with
Joe Biden we can now create a record a
reference point to go through the
various elements of this because this is
a I would call it relatively common
assertion
perpetuated by right-wing media by
right-wing politicians and it is Flowing
down to just random right-wing voters
the claims are numerous one of the
claims that's often used to say the
border is open is you will hear things
like we're catching so many people at
the border because Biden opened it by
definition if we are catching people if
we are stopping people if we are taking
people into custody by definition the
border is not open now when you want to
look at has policy changed have numbers
changed is there something tangible
maybe with the wall or with border
agents that Joe Biden has changed
you find that very little has actually
changed the Biden Administration has
increased the capacity of shelters and
processing centers at the border to
better manage the flow of migrants but
that's not evidence of an open border
it's evidence of being able to more
quickly and more efficiently say who is
merely Crossing illegally and needs to
be put into sort of the deportation flow
and who is seeking Asylum and needs to
be put into that bureaucratic process
neither of those are evidence that the
border is open in addition to that there
are border security claims Biden
demolished border security
there's no evidence of that and you can
find each aspect of this widely
documented by the relevant agencies
funding requests for Customs and Border
Protection under Biden are almost
identical to under Trump when it comes
to how much money is being requested by
the respective administrations for
border security in general
Staffing levels when you say oh well
Trump had way more border patrol than by
that's absolutely not the case U.S
border Patrol Staffing levels were
slightly higher under Obama around 21
000 total
under Trump they were in the 19 000
range plus or minus a few hundred border
agents under Biden they're in that same
19 000 range Plus or by a plus or minus
a few hundred so Staffing levels
identical
funding requests essentially identical
um beyond that what about policy what
about policy on turning people around or
taking Asylum requests or whatever the
case may be border authorities you may
be shocked to hear under Biden are
enforcing immigration laws just like
under Trump immigrants continue to be
expelled detained or allowed in based on
the same standard as to whether they are
passing initial screenings and what
exactly their business in the United
States is the Biden Administration
although they did stop construction of
the wall
few hundred miles of wall uh the Biden
Administration is repairing all existing
border barriers adding detection
technology to make it easier for border
patrol to identify where do we need to
go
I'm not even telling you these things
because I like or dislike them I'm just
telling you what the truth is about
border policy it is absolutely the case
that Biden hasn't added any new barriers
which I think is the right policy
because the wall was quite a silly idea
but Joe Biden is fully funding the
repair of existing barriers that were
already there okay so you have two
groups of people you have people that
are coming to quote sneak in as the
traditional illegal immigration is sort
of characterized and then you have
people coming to seek Asylum and then in
addition to that you do have people who
are coming over for work legally uh or
coming over for work illegally but then
going back to Mexico there's all of
these different scenarios
all of those categories are being
handled the same way that they were
being handled under Donald Trump you can
agree with the policy or disagree with
it you can say we should have some kind
of permanent status uh for uh so-called
dreamers or we should not you can say I
like the wall or I don't like the wall
fine everybody is entitled to that
opinion but in order to really talk
about this we have to acknowledge that
funding hasn't materially changed from
Trump to Biden border Staffing hasn't
materially changed from Trump to Biden
Joe Biden is repairing existing border
barriers Joe Biden is funding new
detection technology for areas of the
border that are that are more remote and
as far as policy goes we have the title
42 thing
which Trump put in and then Biden's
looking getting rid of but it's not
clear whether so there's that but beyond
that we have evidence of nothing more
than another completely fabricated
talking point that's the truth the
border is not open Ron DeSantis donors
are increasingly worried that he can't
handle a national campaign for the
Republican nomination particularly
against Donald Trump and I have to tell
you the evidence is increasingly
pointing that way think for a moment
we're going to get into the data and the
concerns from DeSantis donors in a
moment but think for a moment on the one
hand you have Ron DeSantis he's got a
new book he's speaking all over the
country he's going to Staten Island and
he's going to Manhattan and he's going
all over the place speaking everywhere
being interviewed getting tons of
positive press from Fox News and his
polling is going down
and meanwhile you have Donald Trump
potentially going to get arrested any
day
holding a rally on the 30th anniversary
of the Waco Siege in Waco Texas foam
ending violence all of this stuff
and his polls are going up despite
middle of the night all caps rants on
Truth social and so on and so forth that
doesn't look good for Ron DeSantis and
this is indeed the concern among many
DeSantis donors there's a good NBC news
article Ron desantis's donors and allies
question if he's ready for 2024. at a
recent Gathering of 16 prominent
Republicans a number of DeSantis
supporters discussed if he should run
against Trump or wait until 2028 and
that 2028 question we've increasingly
been talking about many of you have
emailed me and said DeSantis although he
looks like he's almost 60 he's only 44
years old he could wait he could wait
until 2028 when there will be no Trump
he could even wait until 2032 if he
wanted to it's not clear that with the
higher polling he would be willing to do
that but if the polling declines maybe
he would
um NBC News writes Ron DeSantis may be
missing his moment a number of his
donors and allies are worried uh his
recent stumble suggests he may not be
ready for a brutal fight against Donald
Trump some feel DeSantis needs to
accelerate his timeline to run for the
Republican nomination and begin directly
confronting Trump if he is to have any
chance of thwarting Trump's momentum
others believe DeSantis should sidestep
Trump altogether and wait until 2028. it
is true that with the anticipation
having built for months and months now
Donald Trump having announced in the
days right after the November of 22
midterms and actively campaigning at
this point his first rally was over the
weekend and we'll talk about that
how long can DeSantis build anticipation
at the beginning you can accurately say
he's building anticipation and he's
polling strongly as he starts the
misstep as his lack of Charisma oozes
out of every pore and as his polling
starts to sort of drift down
we can no longer call it building
anticipation it's something else and
maybe it is missing the moment the
article continues at a Sunday luncheon
it's not a lunch it's a luncheon and
that's how you know it's serious
business at a Sunday luncheon following
the annual Red Cross ball in Palm Beach
Florida a group of 16 prominent
Republicans described by one attendee as
a mix of DeSantis backers and Trump
Skeptics discussed misgivings about
DeSantis is standing for the future if
he tussles with the former president
quote they liked him many of them might
even support him but they thought on
balance that his long-term future was
better without him trying to take Trump
head on he will get scarred up
the article mentions some specific
donors including billionaire shipping
Goods magnate Richard yoline and his
wife Elizabeth who's five hundred
thousand dollars in Combined
contributions make them among the most
generous donors to DeSantis 2022
campaign
um a person familiar with the strategy
around Uline spending said that right
now quote the breaks are pumped the
polling really made different people
pause a spokesperson for the ulines is
declining to comment it is absolutely
true
that the polling is no Beauty to write
home about if you look at recent polling
you do see that it's very solid for
Trump in just about every way a very
recent Harris X Harris poll has Trump 12
ahead of DeSantis and that's one of
that's one of desantis's better
standings to be perfectly Frank uh a
premise poll has Trump 24 ahead of
DeSantis among registered voters and 30
ahead among all respondents uh a yougov
poll has trumped 15 ahead of DeSantis
now the Counterpoint is DeSantis hasn't
even announced yet and having numbers
this strong when you're not even running
suggests that if DeSantis announces he's
going to get a surge a boost a swelling
for lack of a better term of his polling
that may be the case the problem is as I
mentioned that's a stronger argument
before everybody's talking about
DeSantis for four months and he's doing
interviews and book tours and speeches
and getting the best possible press he
can get from Fox News
once you have months and months of that
it starts to feel as though his
potential is increasingly baked into
existing polling and there's less of a
boost to be had with an announcement so
I don't know what's going to happen it's
not for me to advise Republicans nor is
anybody asking me to advise Republicans
but my concern for DeSantis from day one
has been his lack of Charisma and
seeming desire to be above Trump when
he's asked well Trump said this what do
you say he says I don't spend my time
criticizing Republicans uh fine that may
that may play well in Florida but it's
not striking me as the strongest
positioning for fighting Trump in a
national campaign I want to hear from
you what do you think about desantis's
chances as we are about to enter April
of 2023 are they display dating can they
still be pumped up let me know what you
think in a comment we'll follow up and
see what's on your minds
one of our sponsors today is Leisure of
NYC offering Ultra comfortable fair
trade men's clothing at fair prices guys
know it can be very tough to find good
boxers and t-shirts the search is over
because all boxer briefs by Leisure of
NYC are made with amazingly soft
moisture wicking viscose from bamboo
super lightweight like air but it
doesn't Bunch up and it's also great for
the planet Leisure of NYC also makes
really great supima cotton crew neck
t-shirts less than one percent of men's
Basics today are made with supima cotton
it is the best out there it feels like
Silk quite frankly you can walk around
in a scratchy t-shirt all day or you can
enjoy the cloud soft feel of supima
cotton and actually love the shirt
you're wearing these are my go-to
t-shirts and boxers nothing else even
comes close to providing this level of
comfort and all of their products are
fair trade and made sustainably go pick
up the most comfortable t-shirts and
boxers you will ever own but hurry
because they often sell out especially
the boxers go to davidpackman.com
NYC and you will get 15 off with the
code Pacman at checkout and the link is
down below
the David pakman show continues to be
funded primarily by our audience we have
something called the membership program
so you get perks in exchange for your
support you can sign up at
joinpakman.com we do an extra show every
day for our members we also provide
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show for you much earlier in the
day than the show is otherwise published
as well as invitations to the members
only Town Hall events and a private
sound board a for our members where you
get the vast majority of the clips I
have on my soundboard the United States
will be the first nation to land an
astronaut on if you want to go to Nars
yourself uh yes also another member
benefit you can sign up at
joinpakman.com all right let's get into
what was an insane weekend Donald Trump
held his first official 2024 rally now I
know the year is 2023. what I mean is
the first rally for his 2024 campaign
and it went bad very quickly the
location was Waco Texas we should not
ignore the significance of on the 30th
Anniversary roughly of The Siege at Waco
of the Branch Davidians that Donald
Trump chose to hold his rally in that
very location and in fact he opened the
rally with totally apocalyptic messaging
about how 2024 is the final battle and
uh using exactly that type of disastrous
imagery that is often associated with
the Waco Siege
and 2024 is the final battle that's
going to be the big one is it if you put
me back in the White House their rain
will be over and America will be a free
Nation once again again coming as a
surprise to many of us that America is
not currently a free nation very
confusing statement
[Applause]
[Music]
they know that we are the only ones who
can stop them they know that classic and
standard fascistic messaging where I
alone can fix it you know there's never
been a movement like this and that's
true of our country that's true in the
history of almost every country let's
hope
Mega make America great again America
First Call whatever you want
but I will tell you there's never been
in history look at this crowd as far as
the eye can see we flew over it was a
beautiful sight as far as the eye
concerned now the crowd was animated at
this early stage of the very very long
rally but they very quickly settled and
quieted down including When Donald Trump
bragged about his passing a brain injury
screening test which many people uh I
guess are not finding as convincing as
maybe they once did
say should I do
should I do some of them at all
and you know it was after that
it was after that that nobody called me
stupid anymore it was right
because I never liked that narrative I
don't like the word stupid but other
people are very stupid
he doesn't like the word he doesn't like
the narrative as applied to himself but
he'll immediately apply it to others
Donald Trump did very aggressively go
after Ron DeSantis he even told it
wasn't even a sir story it was uh he
came to me with tears in his eyes story
it's it's beyond parody at this point
Congressman Wesley that was a good
speech you guys
but they've been very loyal but I'm a
loyalist and and when a man comes to me
tears in his eyes
he said almost nothing in the polls it's
crazy how many men big strong guys are
constantly crying around Trump and he's
fighting somebody that's at 42 and he's
got almost 30 million dollars in the
bank yeah he was crying like a dog said
almost nothing he's got no cash
and I said I can't give you an
endorsement there's no way you can win
you're dead
but he fought a little bit like 150 he
was certainly know Jim Jordan that I can
tell you right he forwarded a little bit
just a little bit on impeachment hoax
number one impeachment hooks number two
meaning on television because I didn't
know him very well but I saw him so he
came and he really wanted I said you
can't win can you how do you can win sir
if you endorsed me I'll win please
please sir endorse me
sir you're such a good president I just
need the endorsement I'm dead
and I said all right let's give it a
shot because honestly the secretary of
agriculture okay anyway so people just
bursting into tears around Trump all the
time at another very bizarre moment
Trump claimed that a very famous man
recently asked him how he puts his
clothing on
I had a man come up to be a very famous
man almost everybody probably would have
heard of a businessman
I saw him about two weeks ago he said to
me could I ask you I never even liked
them very much to be honest but he did
say it he said could I speak to you for
a second
Mr President sir
take it I said take what
your coffee sir
I wouldn't know what to do well we're
very proud of the former president he
passed a brain injury screening test and
he also dresses himself all by himself
every single day and that alone probably
makes him qualified to do something I
don't know uh Donald Trump with a very
um a very important message to women for
inclusivity in 2024.
I never liked horse face I never liked
[Applause]
that wouldn't be the one right there is
no one we have a great first lady
yeah
so uh a very inviting message of Trump's
respect for women there as you can see
referring of course to Stormy Daniels
Donald Trump once again playing up this
entire baby bonuses thing we will
support baby bonuses so many people like
that for the new baby boom that will be
coming
we need babies all of this is we need
babies now of course we have a sort of
baby bonus already it's called a child
tax credit Democrats and many on the
left want to increase it and make it
permanent it would be a baby bonus it
would be an incentive to have children
which whether you like that or not it's
what Trump is talking about but they
don't want to do that and much like with
NAFTA and usmca it seems Trump's plan is
sort of like to get rid of what we have
and replace it with the exact same thing
but to give it a different name Donald
Trump continuing the attacks on a New
York Manhattan D.A Alvin Bragg calling
New York prosecutors absolute human scum
but the two lead prosecutors absolute
human scum yeah
1A Hillary Clinton lawyer from a Hillary
Clinton Law Firm do you believe does
anybody know why they say Clinton I I
mean the Marjorie Taylor Greene says
Clinton and she's from the south and
Trump says Clinton and he's from Queens
is it a deliberate sort of pejorative
sort of the way some people might say
Tulsi gabbard I don't know I don't know
who would say that uh what is it what is
it about that and then lastly Trump
bringing back the creepy Q Anon music
and bemoaning how airports function
Nation where once revered airports are
dirty they're a crowded mess you sit and
wait for hours and then are notified
that the plane won't leave and they have
no idea
when it will Trump is saying this
minutes before getting onto his private
plane and taking off and flying directly
home so not not the most relatable
moment of the speech so dangerous
rhetoric
a semi-comatos crowd as the speech went
longer and longer you know you wait all
day in the direct sun with the fetid
porta-potties and next thing you know
the speech finally starts and it's a
snoozer so I I sympathize with the crowd
in a sense I would not go to one of
these things but where I want to go next
is someone we know did go to this thing
and he stood in the Sun and he got some
wild material for us that's Luke Beasley
let's talk about that next our
correspondent and occasional guest host
Luke Beasley whose YouTube channel you
can find at davidpackman.com Luke was on
the ground at the very very disturbing
Trump rally in Waco Texas over the
weekend Luke spoke to a number of people
the topics were wide-ranging they
included gay marriage they included
crisis actors at Sandy Hook it is 2023
don't adjust your TV screen
um it included philosophical questions
about how do we really know anything and
it also included of course George Soros
let's start with the topic of gay
marriage here is Luke inquiring to a
gentleman and I'm using that term
loosely uh about gay marriage let's
listen so what's inherently more about
gay marriage
it is anti-life and is anti-vital Maybe
anti-life
does not produce kids and the marriage
do you think it should be illegal for
two straight people who decide not to
have kids get married no I believe they
should still get married but then that's
my library
it is not anti-life in the same way but
they're not reproducing just like two
gay people don't reproduce
whoa I get what you're saying basically
are you talking about people who know
they're infertile and yet they want to
get married is that what you're saying
any example of that one too you're
saying ban infernal people from getting
married even straight couples
no because at the end of the day they
could still adopt kids and raise them
gay people can adopt kids right I don't
believe they should there's no recent
reports about a gay couple this is what
you call just ping-ponging from one
topic to another
gay people shouldn't get married because
they can't produce kids neither can
infertile couples and also some couples
don't want to have kids well but they
should be able to get married because
they can adopt but gay people can also
adopt well but gay people shouldn't be
allowed to adopt this is you you really
can't good for Luke but you really can't
talk to these folks well that is known
to abuse their kids look up the stats if
I do I can find you about 13 gazillion
examples of straight couples abusing
their kids yeah so then he goes to the
child abuse meme this is what it was
this it's everywhere this stuff is
everywhere at these rallies it doesn't
make any sense here's a guy who's
wearing an Alex Jones was right t-shirt
who repeats a lot of the Sandy Hook
conspiracies from more than a decade ago
that even Alex Jones has since recanted
although you could argue Alex Jones
recanted only for legal reasons but okay
let's take a listen to this one so
you're saying you don't think Sandy Hook
parents were actually being harassed and
they had to move multiple times which
you can see that they actually had to do
that pardon me these parents are just
lying
do I think they're lying
the question is are this are the Sandy
Hook parents lying that they were being
harassed really
I really want to answer that question
man because I don't really by the way
it's just so everybody knows this guy's
a Christian okay oh no I don't know if
they're lying you know
my point is my point is when I see a
parent crying because their kid got
murdered in a mass shooting
my first instinct is to trust them and
not the guy who makes money lying about
them what about what about I mean I I do
believe that there was people that was
uh what they what I guess they called uh
uh there's some some crisis actors I
mean how do you explain that the crisis
actors
see this is a very interesting moment
how do you explain that there were
crisis actors what are you talking about
that's not you're assuming something
that you haven't actually demonstrated
and they were caught in certain
different places I mean they were in the
same place how do you explain that
government
I don't trust the government but I trust
the fact okay what are the facts the
facts are that
parents lost their children and then a
man by the name of Alex Jones lied about
that and said there was Crisis actors in
fact a nonsense
or something because you know what I
believe I believe the only reason it
they're doing this is because they're
gonna they've got to take him down right
it's all a conspiracy to take Alex Jones
down over things Alex Jones chose to say
has since recanted and which we know not
to be true well it seems like a pretty
big unforced error then we went to a
woman who was uh very confused visibly
confused I would even say about why
Trump would be arrested this is pretty
interesting because it gets very
philosophical how do we know anything
how can anything be proven in a court of
law well I don't even know who's Ellen
braggen what's up uh he's the Manhattan
district attorney and he's seems to be
reportedly considering arresting Trump
What charges in regard to the Stormy
Daniels money payment
to our meeting so how can they prove
that that was actually occurred see
that's the whole thing where it comes
down to how do we know it is true what
is real and that's where everything in
this time comes down to a spiritual
reality so her view is it's impossible
to ascertain Truth at all so all we can
do is find a religion to follow which
simply tells us what is true pretty
convenient I have to say if it works for
you I can see why that would be much
more satisfying and pleasing than
understanding the chaos of the real
world the only way you can know it is
true is to believe that there's absolute
truth do
ah you know the reason America is having
a problem is because we need to get back
to God can I ask a quick question so if
it's not like
evidence here you and I can look at okay
is this something that occurred how do
we feel about it instead it's a
spiritual decision to understand truth
right how do you and I come to some
understanding of uh one reality if my
spiritual truth is different good who's
evil I'm sorry between good and evil I'm
saying of my spiritual like if
spiritually I were to feel that Trump is
bad because of his
the anti-democratic views or actions he
took as president and then you
spiritually felt he was good how would
we come to some sort of agreement or
even understand each other's side if
it's not based on kind of empirical
information
well that's a whole big you could call
it a hurricane of a conversation that I
would love to get into all the knitties
and gritties of it but probably not
between here
all right yeah so anyway how do we know
anything is really the question and
that's where religion comes in for this
woman but of course it's like which
religion you've got a thousand religions
and they very often conflict with each
other uh Luke then spoke to the first
guy to raise the topic of George Soros
and Luke's pretty slick here in the
questions he's asking sort of trying to
get at the anti-semitic undertones of
all of this the guy kinda Dodges it a
little take a look at this look who's
running the country our borders are free
to come and go in the country
um bad but more like more of his
puppeteers which are who
Soros George stores media in general
yeah why is it they use that particular
term puppeteers in relationships because
uh uh he has enough money he can buy
anybody he uh how much money has he
given to Joe Biden
I have no idea
and there it is how do you know he's
controlling him because that's what I
read That's What I Hear and uh do you
believe the election story no no who
don't no
no I mean I believe that there are
people probably voted more often than
they should you know and I believe
there's a lot of people who were not
registered that did vote but how do you
vote if you're not registered it's never
clear but I think
I don't
get your evidences all the other people
here right which in that particular
crowd there's a noticeable lack of
evidence I'm glad the guy is identifying
that there's none yeah oh my gosh okay
don't you feel it's pretty dangerous to
say the election Stone if you don't have
evidence
you're right I'm saying sorry I meant to
specify Trump because he says a lot well
I've been thinking there's when you're
got that much money and stuff you can
sweep a lot of things under the rug
until the rug's too full right and that
starts but if you don't have evidence I
could say anything about anything you're
a murderer I don't have an Evidence but
you could have swooped on the road you
know what I mean yeah that's right when
you're a politician you're just sitting
there as a target for anybody who wants
to accuse you of anything
this is if you're confused by what this
guy's saying that's the right reaction
don't you think it's dangerous for
people's belief in the legitimacy of our
democracy to say it was stolen it
doesn't work anymore without solid
evidence
yeah
he agrees it's extremely dangerous what
he's doing so then for me I would have a
really hard time even if I like other
policies supporting a political leader
if the most important part of our
political process are democratic
institutions and process is being uh
kind of assaulted by his rhetoric yeah I
think he talks too much okay so anyway
yeah Trump probably shouldn't be saying
that the guy says same guy here with
another woman I think this might be his
wife but I don't know apparently his
wife doesn't believe January 6th is
really a big deal that should even
really be talked about very much
Trump rallies where they start turning
cars over and burning them
oh my God
did we just talk about we're not
fighting yeah
we believe what do we believe about
January 6th it's all a media okay it's
just a media story it's not even real
years ago yeah why do they keep bringing
up a rehash in different ways I can tell
you because it was an attempt to subvert
the world of people and block the
certification of a president got elected
no see the guys it's that simple why
bother learning about things just do
what this woman says you just say no it
was an attempt to subvert the will of
the people and install a president who
didn't actually win no wow that's a
pretty good argument ma'am I have to say
uh and then last clip here here's a
woman who believes Trump won but she's
very confused what makes you believe
Trump won
because he has the majority of people
even though the official vote counts
don't show that okay now did you notice
that she says look around here
there are 3 500 people here in Waco
Texas who support Trump clearly that
proves that a country of 330 million
voted for him
fraud what people did
I deceive
what are you saying looking around here
helps you to see that the majorities
with Trump
so we love president Trump the American
people love America here's kind of an
analogy
do you know who Taylor Swift is
the pop artist yeah so I've gone she's
she's great I've gone to one of her
concerts before and it's this massive
Stadium probably three four times the
amount of people who will be at this
event there to see Taylor Swift and so
there it would seem like everyone knows
and loves Taylor Swift but we understand
if you polled Americans it probably
wouldn't be a majority who are fans of
Taylor Swift and so that kind of gives
you a sense of
when you're within a public and see
everyone good for Luke he's trying but
it's not getting through loves a
particular thing or is a fan of a
particular person when in reality the
broader world doesn't actually match
that
and so we have to look at things like
data empirical information such as our
election results to understand what the
actual majority wants
he won Bayern Square
[Laughter]
I mean that's pretty
he got the majority he we love he didn't
even get the majority of the popular
vote Pam is the American people he has
stood for Israel he has stood for The
Unborn he doesn't drink
right he has good morals he has good
kids he has good grandkids and we are
blessed to have him
the president of the United States
there you go hard to uh hard to argue
against folks who don't actually care
about reality but they care about I
don't know it looks like people here
like them it seems pretty good to me
really nice job by Luke and and a range
of topics a range of people really good
stuff and we'll have all of these clips
if you're just listening today you want
to see what the the whole scene is like
visually and I do recommend that we'll
have these clips up on our YouTube
channel youtube.com the davidpackman
show and we'll also have them on our
Instagram and on Tick Tock these clips
are going to be everywhere believe me
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
all right let's look at a couple of
other things from the Trump rally over
the weekend there were a number of
esteemed dignitaries and very high
profile guests at this rally in Waco
Texas to kick off the 2024 campaign for
Donald Trump one such dignitary was Ted
Nugent and Ted Nugent kicked off the
rally in Waco by saying that Russian I'm
sorry Ukrainian President Vladimir
zielinski is a quote homosexual weirdo
which I have to admit I have not heard
before
I want my money back I didn't authorize
any money to Ukraine is some homosexual
weight weirdo
yeah I want my money back okay sounding
like a whining child but in all
seriousness as we've talked about before
some of the biggest Applause lines among
the American right wing over the last
two years are overtly homophobic and
transphobic lines and that was indeed
the case at the Trump rally maybe my
favorite moment from any recent rally
including this one was a guy who got up
on stage and instead of promising to fix
the supply chain he said he would fix
the chain supply
I've got a plan to fix the chain supply
oh these people uh if you if you were
aware of the distinct lack of chains
that we have in this country this guy is
going to fix it for you
[Music]
yeah uh so anyway very soon chains will
be back in the United States here's
another really interesting moment one of
Trump's attorneys who also moonlights as
an anchor for right side broadcasting
Christina Bob she spoke to a guy
who brings up that he served in the
Marines and then she says oh what's your
MOS now that's just a specialty it's a
it's super General it's like oh avionics
or like intelligence it's super just
super super General Moses are not
classified in any way or secret or
confidential and the guy reacts weirdly
to the point where five different
current and former Marines wrote to me
and said David this guy's lying no
former Marine what answered this
question in this way you tell me what
you think is this guy making it up here
we go did you serve I did where did you
Marine Maybe too what was your MLF
I was special oh I see okay
I flew into places okay where were you
dark places where were you stationed I I
uh can't go into detail okay
it's all super super secret now again
MOS just means military occupational
specialty it's just a super General role
were you in personnel and administration
were you in logistics the guy could have
just said I was in intelligence I was in
avionics I was whatever it's really
tough to tell whether it's completely
made up but again current Marines wrote
to me and said David this stuff stinks
to high heaven this guy is just straight
up making it up if he did serve and he's
just wacky right now because he's you
know infected with the Trump virus fine
but uh many members of the military in
our audience
extraordinarily skeptical about this
guy's story then a a January 6th
indictee as I understand it named Mickey
was there and gave a very strange
interview is the only way I can describe
it guys in isolation 51 of those days
Fred nothing but the roof over my head
my back foot in my mouth my Lord Jesus
my God Almighty and the support of a
nation and I knew that in my heart I
knew that
my negative 48 family my proxmanian
family the whole world can cause crazy
if you don't care yeah oh I don't I
could not have done it
without my protest manian family do my
trip you don't know dematria is one Biz
to CS3 anyway I'm not going to continue
with this it goes on for a long time but
quite it just to the untrained diet
seems like very very significant mental
illness here's another guy who wants to
do a citizen's arrest of Alvin Bragg
there's an idea Alvin Bragg of course
the Manhattan district attorney who
might might might indict Donald Trump
for itself arrest Alvin Bragg uh Alvin
Bragg is overstepping his boundaries we
the people are calling for the arrest of
Alvin Bragg four crimes of treason
election interference I don't even know
if that's a crime but election
interference obstruction that's the
critical moment from the interview
he's Furious and he's confident that
Alvin Bragg should be arrested but he's
not actually sure whether the things
he's mentioning to justify Alvin Bragg's
arrest are crimes beautifully emblematic
of this entire thing Josh is even lying
to a grand jury Trump done nothing wrong
we're here to show support for the
greatest president ever Donald Trump
arrest Alvin Bragg you know in South
Carolina you could do citizens arrest
yeah so if Alvin Bragg ever comes to
South Carolina arrest them there you go
so a very very patriotic idea there and
then
um uh what else do I have here he uh
lastly here is a woman who says she's a
South African Maga preacher
who had God come to her in a dream and
told her to move to the United States
and try to support Donald Trump which
again
this would likely be medicated in most
psychiatric situations amazing what's
your name and where are you from my name
is lindian hopley and I am a South
African Mega preacher no
Africa now I'm living in America because
he told me that
and in the dream that I had president
Trump was in it so Yep this is totally
normal I'm all about just praying for
this country and seeing God get his full
reward that's amazing where do you live
here in the United States I'm in DFW so
we came down with a trump train with all
the Texans you know going crazy all the
truck going crazy is about right it's
just honking and going wild it's so
great to see how many patriots there are
and so many supporters of just this
great movement fantastic and what is it
about President Trump that you love so
much
well to be honest I just started
dreaming about him I am you know I have
a prophetic gift and the Lord started
speaking to me about him totally not
just conversations with the Lord she's a
prophet and in my one dream I
might because I'm totally not political
I'm a minister I travel around the world
you had me full
he said Shine Your Light and don't hide
it underneath a basket so I was a wild
party girl and had an encounter with no
you were I I don't see it
but what I loved about this is that I
actually in one of my dreams I sat in
front of prison Chomp and I knew he was
giving me some type of job you know I
was kind of like and I said to I'm the
Lord in my dream I said I don't want to
lose my Ministry for this all right so
anyway as we've talked about before
mental illness not a joke very sad need
to increase access to mental health
treatment in the United States let's
leave it there with the South African
Maga preacher but that is what this is
where we are right now as far as the
Trump movement and it is a really scary
and sad thing Donald Trump did threaten
death and destruction in a dangerous 1am
rant the other night this is very scary
stuff Trump posting to truth social
quote what kind of person can charge
another person in this case a former
president of the United States who got
more votes than any sitting president in
history and leading candidate by far for
the Republican Party nomination with a
Capital C crime when it is known by all
that no crime has been committed and
also known that potential death and
destruction in such a false charge could
be catastrophic for our Capital C
country why and who would do such a
thing only a degenerate psychopath that
truly hates the USA this is Donald Trump
saying if Alvin Bragg indicts me it will
lead to death and Destruction for the
country and it will be Alvin Bragg's
fault not Trump's fault for inciting the
death and destruction or uh uh uh I
guess the people who commit the death
and Destruction for listening to Trump
extremely scary stuff the New York Times
reporting Trump escalating attacks
raises Specter of violence if he is
charged
um and mediaite Reporting about Donald
Trump making a post where he's holding a
baseball bat seemingly threatening
himself the district attorney Alvin
Bragg which Trump subsequently deleted I
hope there is not violence but I am very
worried that there will be because of
the direction this is going my only
thought is
it actually seems like Trump supporters
aren't that motivated to go out and
protest and commit commit acts of
violence they seem sort of resigned in a
way let's hope they are lazy and
pacified and don't heed Trump's calls
that's the Hope right now all right real
quick I don't want to spend a lot of
time on cat turd this isn't really a
program where cat turd is a big thing
but Donald Trump hit an absolute Rock
Bottom Rock Bottom new low posting cat
turd polls to truth social
I managed to get through that mostly
without laughing yes Donald Trump in an
act of desperation to show how well he
is doing against Ron DeSantis in the
Republican primary over the weekend
posted new poll just out and when you
look closely you realize that the poll
is from the cat
the poll is from the the cat turd uh
Twitter account this is a um an account
that pushes right wing nonsense it isn't
a poll it's quite literally just like a
Twitter survey where a couple hundred
thousand followers of cat turd voted and
Trump did have 69 of the vote uh
compared to Ron desantis's 24. and I
don't know that there's really that much
commentary to do here other than Trump
is posting cat turd in in the middle of
the night is not typically the or
actually this one was in the afternoon
to be completely clear it's not
typically what you would expect from a
former president cat turd is not big
among Obama cat turd notably not big
among George W bush but Trump posting
cat turd and it's all getting very sad
and very very uh tragic if uh if I'm
totally upfront with you all right let's
take a quick break we're going to get to
book Banning we're going to get to the
regrowth of uh of toes through prayer
and lots of other important things after
this very short break
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show a book
Banning Republican is very quickly
learning about the potentially
unintended consequences of his own
actions as a parent is now using the law
to try to get the Bible banned and I
have to tell you it makes a lot of sense
lgbtqnation.com reports book ban
lawmaker quote very sad and I don't know
why I find very sad to be funny that a
parent is using his law to ban the
sex-ridden Bible the pair parents said
that if lesser books have been banned
then the Bible which discusses
infanticide rape and bestiality is not
appropriate for kids I mean that it
makes a lot of sense a Utah parrot reads
the article has challenged the Bible
under a state law Banning pornographic
or indecent materials in schools it has
been used to remove books by mostly
lgbtq plus and black authors from
shelves in a book challenge submitted to
Davis School District the unnamed parent
called the Bible quote one of the most
sex-ridden books around according to the
Salt Lake Tribune
uh Utah state representative Ken Ivory
who sponsored HB 374 described the
request as a political stunt that would
rain drain School resources there was a
purpose to the bill and this kind of
stuff it's very unfortunate now of
course that's true the purpose of the
bill was not to actually ban all of this
type of content it was only to ban the
content that this guy doesn't like and
that is fundamentally what this is all
about and if we are to say let's apply
their standards the Bible must be bad
that's the reality now I'm not out there
advocating for anything to be banned but
if these are the standards graphic
descriptions of sexual activity
one example is of course Song of Solomon
7 1-9 where a woman describes her
Lover's body in sensual detail it's
basically a romance novel several
stories in the Bible are just filled
with explicit sexual content rape incest
Genesis 19 Angels save lot and his
family from the destruction of Sodom and
Gomorrah lot offers his virgin daughters
to the men to be raped in exchange for
their safety edgy doesn't really quite
cover that storyline I must say Ezekiel
23 20 graphic description of Two Sisters
engaging in sexual activity with
multiple partners Genesis 38 the story
of judah's son put to death by God for
wickedness and right before he dies he
engages in sexual activity with his
daughter-in-law who is disguised as a
sex worker
folks if this is actually the standard
the content and not whether it's
Christian content or black content or
whatever then the Bible must be banned
of course that is not the point of these
bills I'm sure you understand but they
want there to be a special status for
the Bible and I believe that if we have
these standards they should apply to all
reading materials Bible included you
know we often say when it comes to Faith
healing I'll be impressed when they can
actually regrow someone's amputated limb
of course it never happens we now have a
woman claiming that indeed three
amputated toes were regrown now there's
no evidence her toes were amputated
there's no evidence that anything grew
back they're not providing any such
evidence but here she is she attends
James River Church in Missouri she
claims prayer regrew three toes it's a
miracle so I had three toes that were
amputated in a terrible accident I heard
the word for Creative Miracles and I
thought well I certainly have a creative
miracle that I might need I need three
toes to grow back the person next to me
said do you want new toes and I was like
well sure all the women got down and
they prayed over my foot and I decided
to take my shoe off to see what was
happening when he said let's see the
progress or if anything's happened and
when I did I had to grab the person next
to me and say do you see what I see and
I saw three toes that we're forming and
now there's length to them tonight I can
stand on my tippy toes right do you
understand I can stand on tippy toes no
I couldn't do that because I didn't have
those boots to be on
it's pretty remarkable stuff folks and
obviously they're presenting no evidence
whatsoever here's Pastor John Lindell of
the church who says he has the proof but
he's not going to share it with the
people demanding the proof because
they're not in favor of what he's doing
it's not up to him to validate this
stuff as you know there's been quite a
fewer uh I like that a few Roar on
social media relative to the girl with
the toes yep because her Miracle is real
it's genuine uh people are saying well
if it's genuine why aren't you why
aren't you doing anything with it to
publicize it there's a couple of reasons
I want to say to you first of all
um I'm less interested in improving to
people but I know God did than I am in
protecting sheep who are vulnerable
right now of course this is total BS and
this is where it really becomes BS he
says he's not interested in proving it
to people the whole point of Evangelical
Christianity is to uh proselytize it's
to evangelize it's to bring people in
this is the greatest thing they can do
it's the greatest Mitzvah and of course
I'm using the term Mitzvah
tongue-in-cheek because these they're
Evangelical Christians so why would I
use the term Mitzvah I understand it's
the greatest thing you can do the whole
point of these religions is to
perpetuate themselves by getting people
to convert
what would more powerfully get people to
convert
than proving that you regrew three
amputated toes for comparison I I know
I've said explain this to people before
Jews which is the culture I'm from
Judaism there's no proselytizing but
we're not looking to add people to the
ranks even if someone wants to convert
their dissuaded multiple times and it's
a very difficult process so this is a
religion that is all about that their
main point is to spread the gospel and
he has the most powerful tool to do that
that prayer regrew the three toes of a
woman whose toes have been amputated but
he's not going to do it
he's not going to do it it's a missed
opportunity my friend obviously it is
complete and total nonsense we don't
even know whether This Woman's toes were
ever amputated there's no evidence they
grew back there's no evidence of
anything but that is not a big shock to
those of us that have been following the
faith healing movement for a very long
time we have a voicemail number that
number is 219 to David P here's a
voicemail asking a really interesting
question about audio books versus
physical books
hey David this is Ollie from Dallas I
love all of your book recommendations
and I've read quite a few of them but
I've never heard your position on
audiobooks uh one of these audio books
do you think that it's a cheap way of
reading a book or do you think that it's
useful for people who are often you know
busy with a lot of things going on and
just want to you know hear the book and
audio form okay so here's the deal the
answer to our audio books as good as
physical books you have to first say as
good in what way okay I read fiction at
night before going to bed
the physical process of holding the book
and actually reading it is the point so
in that case my fiction reading at night
before going to bed
an audiobook is not a good substitute if
the idea is to get information from a
non-fiction book then the audiobook
while driving in the car at the gym or
whatever is a better substitute so you
have to ask yourself what is it that I'm
trying to do with the book or with the
information there is one thing about
audiobooks that's not quite as as useful
I would say which is that the normal way
we read you read a bunch of lines and
then you go back half a line and then
you double check a word that's a normal
process where you might say to yourself
oh no I don't do that I just read
straightforward no I understand we do it
naturally particularly with more
difficult texts you kind of read back
and go up a line or two you can't really
have that same process with the
audiobooks now I get it you can hit back
15 seconds and hear something again but
it is different in the brain so the
studies that have been done are that
audio books are great substitutes for
physical books in many ways but it is
not not the same experience and so the
the answer to the question is it as good
you have to then follow up and say as
good in what particular way we have a
great bonus show for you today we're
going to talk about the threats and the
suspicious powder sent to Manhattan
district attorney Alvin BRAC we are also
going to talk about the FTC getting
involved in making it easier to quit gym
memberships gym memberships and who is
rokana endorsing in the California
Senate race is it Adam Schiff uh is it
um Barbara Lee
or is it Katie Porter well it is Barbara
Lee we will discuss with you rocana's
endorsement and much more all of it on
the bonus show get access by signing up
at joinpakman.com see you then everybody
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors the most
comfortable men's boxers and t-shirts
you'll ever find are at leisure of NYC
their Ultra Soft bamboo boxers feel as
light as air and their silky smooth
supima cotton crewneck t-shirts are
amazing I love them you'll get 15 off
with code Pacman at davidpackman.com NYC